the european central bank is flooding
the markets with cheap money and growth
projections for the eurozone are rising
what is behind all these good news
that's what i'll be talking about with
oliver rakau from deutsche bank research
mr raqqa first of all let's have a look
at the world economy what does the dbx
tell us about the mood of the global
economy the dbx has declined slightly
however that is covering the fact that
there was some improvement in europe and
germany and some improvement in china
whereas we had some moderation further
moderation in the us for example
so moderation in the u.s
the the growth in china isn't that good
uh well
why
are the growth protections for the
eurozone so good well
the eurozone is one of the major
beneficials
from the falling oil price because
europe is definitely a net consumer of
oil prices of oil whereas the united
states for example are producing and
consuming oil and many asian countries
are actually producers of oils therefore
the decline is major primarily seen in
the european union
let's take a look at the eurozone
especially at greece greece got fresh
money was it for the last time possibly
probably not to be honest we will have
to define a third package or whatever we
in the end call it to have face saving
on both sides
but looking at how the economy has been
doing how the
tax revenues in greece have been doing
over the last couple of weeks and month
it really looks like we have to
at least for some time further support
greece because it cannot yet stand on
its own feet
so what do you think from your point of
view could greece destabilize the
eurozone
this is hard to say because on the one
hand of course greece is very small it
really is a one-off
development because it has been
lacking the european recovery
substantially has put less reforms in
place compared to for example spain so
you could say
it's one of a kind country and it's
smaller that on the other hand
this could well destabilize the european
monetary union because if one country
leaves why don't two or three countries
leave and so far it would be a precedent
and as fragile as the european monetary
union still is that is likely still
better avoided
well the european central bank has
started to flood the markets with cheap
money
the bond buying prop program is worth
about
more than 1 trillion euro that's amazing
what do you think
will they be successful with this
program
we think so we believe that the major
channel for which it will affect the
european economy is through a weaker
exchange rate which should be beneficial
for example for higher import prices
adding to inflation but also for higher
exports
so yes it will be successful but even
the ecb says it's not the one turnaround
momentum we will produce by this we
still need reforms in europe
we will talk about this program later on
and you can watch the full focus
interview on what the ecb is doing right
now on what the quantitative easing
program uh what kind of effects it will
have on dw dot de slash english slash
made in germany